but all the fun is threatened by a
deeply held secret they are seeing
monsters from another world just below
the water surface so there's kind of a
lovecraftian angle to it yeah yeah yeah
warping over the course of the movie
slowly going cthulu
is calling them too i need to learn
about the elder gods of mental
illness
how's it going reject nation greg and
john here we're gonna watch the
trailer uh the teaser trailer for disney
and pixar's
luca i don't know most about this i
actually don't know
really anything about it other than it
takes place in your favorite country
ever
japan japan italian half italian that's
right so we got ryan the last dragon
representing my asian side and
luca representing my italian side and uh
just a little heads up today uh in about
like an hour and a half from filming
this we're supposed to be doing an
interview with uh
two of the directors of writing the last
dragon and one of the writers so keep a
lookout for when that interview is
posted
sometime next week and also going to try
to get a movie reaction for that on the
channel as well in the meantime let's
check out the teaser trailer for
lucca
do anything we just gotta stick together
for each other
animation looks different yeah a little
bit
some slight leica vibes
that's a good call
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
oh i had no clue
what the heck is going on where did you
boys say you were from
[Music]
wow they're they're like wear maids
wow damn that's wild yeah especially if
like all it takes to reveal is water
contacting their skin
when i said i had no idea what this was
about or then it was italian influence
that's
all i really knew oh my goodness that
was surprising
yeah let's see what we got here disney
and pixar's upcoming original feature
film luca is a fun and heartwarming
story about
friendship stepping out of your comfort
zone and two
teenage sea monsters who experience
a life-changing summer wow
there at the end that took me for
surprise
that really took me for a surprise
because i love the
animation style it does feel different
than what i'm used to pixar actually
doing it feels a slight bit like like a
leica movie uh as i pointed out earlier
it goes out saying the animation's
you know freaking brilliant as always
when it comes to pixar i love how
pixar especially lately in the past few
years they really seem to be doing this
thing where they hone in on
cultural influences yeah with coco
soul i feel like there's another
monsters
under represented people but i feel
doing this you know you do get that like
beautiful
escapism with italian culture and
bringing italy to life and the spirit
the soul of all that there
a little bit of uh what was onward
a little bit of that onward vibe too
with creatures who
they look like they're friends i don't
get the impression they're brothers
this combination of like several pixar
movies i feel like we've seen as of late
with a different animation style with
italian culture vibes but i love like
the surprising
sea creature vibe because i thought like
oh it's kind of like we're getting the
ratatouille thing
you know we're getting kind of that like
pleasant hanging out it's
life yeah that's what i thought we were
going into and then come to find out
whoa there's this like supernatural
angle here going on
yeah that was just not expecting and
it's something that it seems like they
are very much aware of it's not like oh
we gotta unlock this potential it's more
like we gotta hide this from people
otherwise i don't know if they're gonna
try and
exploit us or if the village has some
kind of dark history with sea monsters
or whatever i mean given that this
the log line calls them sea monsters i
guess i would imagine that maybe there's
some kind of prejudice involved but yeah
it does look like an italian postcard
from someone's vacation it came to life
and i know they said they did
draw from some like classic film
influences from italy like fellini and
stuff like that then also you know want
to make it like a you know pixar family
adventure this definitely threw me for a
loop and i wonder
how those tones will coalesce basically
how the adventure
sea monster side will match with the
sort of yeah we're just in italy and
we're sort of learning about life and
stepping out of our comfort zone
you know okay i'm learning about this in
real time as we're filming this by the
way
like normally i like to do a little bit
of research beforehand and this was one
of the rare cases i haven't but i found
a more detailed description here
set in a beautiful seaside town on the
italian riviera luca is a coming-of-age
story and you really do get that vibe
oh yeah kind of like call me by your
name
you're not the first person i've heard
referenced
really for like that movie or for this
for this
yes i mean it's a coming of age story in
italy so that's what i thought
about one young boy experiencing an
unforgettable summer like call me by her
name
filled with gelato pasta and endless
scooter rides
lucas shares these adventures with his
newfound best friend okay so it is a
best friend
but all the fun is threatened by a
deeply held secret they are seeing
monsters from another world just below
the water surface so there's kind of a
lovecraftian angle to it yeah yeah yeah
warping over the course of the movie
slowly going cthulu is calling them too
i need to learn about the elder gods and
mental illness
this is charming coming in but you've
got to imagine that there will be some
references for the parents
who know like probably nothing too grim
but they probably will throw in some
lovecraft
you have to do there it's required there
will be a little mermaid reference and
an hb lovecraft
i wonder if something that disney can
often surprise me by
is they will have like a finale
in their movies that often are presented
in so so beautifully but like halfway
through they start getting a little dark
and i just
imagine with this angle because they
call them monsters in the descriptions
yes so i'm wondering if by the finale
it'll just get like
really dark and they'll have some weird
conflict about having to go back to the
sea
or you know having to uh or like what
are they learning about the human nature
side of things
they're probably gonna have to learn to
make the humans accept
like coexist with the sea creatures
because that's what i got from that one
cut across town where it's like
everyone's looking mean and they got
this big old statue of like a monster
being gourd in the middle of town like
why do they have to be here you know
like why why are they here yeah it seems
like a place where you'd have to work
hard to blend in because also just like
you're gonna get hit with water
at some point yeah i loved it i loved
the trailer and i
i actually really enjoyed not knowing
anything about this going in
yeah it was a nice surprise oh jack
villain grace and
jacob tremblay are the are the voice
over the main voiceover dudes and then
oh cool to it
kids all right guys well what did you
think about this trailer leave your
thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button help get us to 800
000 subs last but not least
niraj krishnan you know what pixar's
overdue for having
an indian culture influence pixar film
indians have feelings too
they do there could be one with a
character called niraj
who befriends two influencers who are
wanting to tap into the indian market
jaby kawai and achara kirk and they go
over there they befriend naraj and then
they find out narage
is actually he's actually an ancient
chimera
with several arms yeah yeah yeah he's a
creature of
myth i'm pulling from the wrong culture
smiths right now but you know the
legends has
it that niraj was once the ruler of the
land in his original form but then the
humans
they drove him out and now he has to
just live as a regular guy
that's you like all the other chimeras
who were like you know really
aggressive and stuff he just wanted to
make pottery
i hope you enjoyed this one
you